Kanye West makes a big donation to the
families of George Floyd Ahmad R burry
and Brianna Taylor it's extremely
important to me the rapper's rep
confirmed to et that he's made two
million dollars worth of contributions
to support the families and the legal
defense for our burry and Taylor Kanye
also created a five to nine college plan
while fully covering tuition for Floyd's
six-year-old daughter Gianna
[Applause]
what's more the rapper also donated to
several black owned businesses in his
home state of Illinois and nationwide
amid the ongoing protests sparked by
Floyd's of fatal arrest meanwhile
Kanye's famous wife Kim kardashian-west
has made her own contributions that's
why we're here you know anything we can
do on Monday the mom of four shared a
heartbreaking photo of a girl whose face
was damaged by a rubber bullet while
protesting Floyd's death she captioned
the photo quote does anyone know how I
can get in contact with her I would love
to help her with her medical care if she
needs it the aspiring criminal justice
lawyer also shared a drawing of Floyd on
her Instagram stories with the hashtag
justice for George Floyd along with
posting Floyd's plea for help it was my
responsibility to educate other people
what I was learning at the same time on
Saturday Kim took to the social media
platform with a lengthy message which
she began quote for years with every
horrific murder of an innocent black man
woman or child I have always tried to
find the right words to express my
condolences and outrage but the
privilege I am afforded by the color of
my skin has often left me feeling like
this is not a fight that I can truly
take on my own not today not anymore
the 39 year old went on to say that
she's more than angry adding quote I am
infuriated and I am disgusted I am
exhausted by the heartbreak I feel
seeing mother's father's sister's
brothers and children suffering because
their loved one was murdered or locked
away unjustly for being black
Kim ended her message by pledging that
although she'll never know the pain and
suffering they've endured she will use
her own voice to help amplify those
voices that have been muffled for too
long Kim and Kanye are just a few of the
celebs lending their money and voices to
the black lives matter movement
following the string of murders this
year including a mod R burry who was
shot and killed by armed white residents
on February 23rd while jogging through a
Georgia neighborhood 26 year-old Brianna
Taylor who was fatally shot by police in
her Kentucky home on March 13th and 46
year old George Floyd who died after
former police officer Derek Chavan held
him down by the neck with his knee for
more than eight minutes when he was
arrested for suspicion of forgery
outside a Minnesota deli on May 25th
shavon has since been fired arrested and
charged with second degree murder the
state's attorney general also announced
on Wednesday that the three other since
fired officers involved in the fatal
arrest have also been charged with
aiding and abetting murder following
days of protests Floyd's family and
friends gathered in Minneapolis to
celebrate his life in what was the first
of several memorial services gone home
George get your rest George you changed
the world George
we will keep marching George we won't
keep fighting George we don't turn the
cop George we going Foley George time
out time out time out
[Music]